let's go to our caller from the 803 area
code who's calling today from 803 yes
hello yes who's this hi I've been a I'm
yes I'm from the 803 Columbia South
Carolina and I'm a student University
South Carolina I believe about Trayvon
em and I've been wondering what were
your thoughts on the current wealth gap
in our society and lately in my classes
we've been talking a lot about a lot
about pretty much fascism or war because
of the wealth gap is so wide now and I
wanted to get your opinion on that you
think those are you option but you think
we're heading down one of the other no
no I mean listen successful social
democracies that that properly and
aggressively regulate capitalism have
reduced wealth gaps significantly
they've brought up the bottom they've
put some limits at the top and we know
that there are all sorts of intangible
benefits to reducing the wealth gap not
only do you bring more people into the
sort of participating class as I like to
call it people who are enabled to
participate in society and in the things
that the institutions of society
reducing inequality reduces crime
reducing inequality has all sorts of
intangible positive effects societies
work better when you have lower levels
of inequality the economy is more stable
when you have lower levels of inequality
because the sort of purchasing power is
not so concentrated at one end and among
so few people so I don't think that war
or fascism are the only paths forward in
an unequal Society I think that the
Scandinavian economies are proof of that
I think that there are other economies
that are proof of that and I think that
that that's not the only path forward oh
yes I told you about you know be social
democracies but you know I in land
there's you know the Swedes but also I
just want to know I just mainly pertain
to America because uh you know unlike
those countries we don't invest heavily
in a social program such as like
education or teacher pay you know to
keep a clear dialogue so as far as I
guess with the
the current uh you see the status quo of
the United States what are the paths
forward here yes yes for the United
States because even in the past like you
know I guess even outside United States
but with Germany or even when we're at
this point and AH foure in the beginning
of World War two we get you know the
wealth gap was huge and everyone was
desperate and we decided go war right
and here's the thing here's the thing in
the United States so we'll think about
the United States more specifically the
desire among the voters is already there
basically for economies that look much
more like the Scandinavian economies you
ask people should the government provide
a basic level of health care to
everybody even if they can't pay
two-thirds to three-quarters of
Americans say yes should the United
States tax the very rich in order to
reduce income inequality majority of the
country says yes I could go on okay so
the voters already want that stuff the
problem we have in the United States is
that the desires of the rich and of big
corporations are overwhelmingly likely
to be made into law by our elected
officials compared to if you're just a
random middle-class guy who goes my
votes so we need to fix the political
system fascism I don't think is going to
get us better teacher pay and the other
things that you're talking about and
wars that we're not advocating for it no
you're not okay all right thank you for
the call very important stuff and I
think that there the desire is there we
just need to make it a reality by fixing
the system we have campaign finance as
part of it media consolidation as part
of it we've talked about all of the
things that need to happen and they're
they're big things but fascism and war
are certainly not the paths forward
thank you they're not keep up the good
work do I love the show and I'm
listening thank you really appreciate
the call thank you so much